está inmortalizado en el corazón de su
ciudad natal en la casa donde creció a
300 kilómetros de Buenos Aires el
prodigio del fútbol Lionel Messi está
representado en este mural de Rosario
y marlenzuriaga son los nombres de los
artistas que crearon este mural para
rendirle homenaje a su ídolo durante la
Copa del Mundo
fue una posibilidad de
abrazar su historia también desde desde
la raíz realmente desde la raíz natal de
donde él nació vivió
creció y bueno se desarrolló en estas
callecitas para los locales Leo Messi es
más que un símbolo forma parte de la
identidad de la ciudad
siempre de chiquitos yo me crié con él y
no tanto con el Diego pero sí mucho con
él y hoy en día es un orgullo para los
chicos como Enzo Julián Álvarez es
Santiago Almada que están viviendo un
sueño al lado un sueño que todos aquí en
Rosario comparten con la esperanza de
que algún día la insignia del fútbol
argentino regrese a su ciudad natal es
nuestro sueño verlo volver a Leo al
barrio
la sub-20 con la selección volvió con
los trofeos ahora ya entendemos que es
más difícil pero sigue siendo nuestro
sueño este es probablemente el último
mundial que jugará el gigante del fútbol
a sus 35 años Messi sueña con la única
deuda en su palmarés traer la copa de
Qatar 2022 a territorio argentino y
reafirmar una vez más su huella
indeleble en la historia del fútbol